good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the major problems of the
world
so today's message is be conscious of
your mortality opening you said good you
should just observe if everybody makes a
little effort everybody take a little
time for this piece of life okay not for
your family not for your carrier not for
something else something else just for
this piece of life give it a little time
because this is the most important piece
of life in your life isn't it yes or no
even if you are in love with somebody
still this is the most important piece
of life isn't it so pay some attention
to this how does it happen why have you
taken it for granted believe me you're
not going to be here forever I'll bless
you with a long life but you want to
fall that one day yes or no so do not
take this for granted if you wake up in
the morning tomorrow if you wake up in
the morning
now this is not my wish but I want you
to know of all the people who go to bed
tonight over a million people will not
wake up tomorrow morning and tomorrow if
you and we wake up tomorrow morning is
it not a fantastic thing a million
people did not wake up you woke up is it
not a great thing just look at the
ceiling and smile you are still awake
you still there
and for many many millions of people
somebody whose dear to them did not wake
up so just check those five six people
around you they all woke up wow it's a
fantastic day you woke up and everybody
who matters to you around you woke up is
it not fantastic day you don't think so
yes you don't seem to think so
see hands because the problem is just
this you are living with an idea that
you're immortal when I say you're
immortal
you're not actually thinking you're
immortal but you are not conscious of
your Morales mortality if you are not
conscious of your mortality somewhere
you think you're immortal isn't it
how many moments in a day are you
conscious that you're mortal
if you were conscious would you have
time to crib would you have time to
fight with somebody would you have time
to do some rubbish with your life if you
knew if you are conscious that you're
mortal you would do nothing other than
what is absolutely needed for you and
everybody around you this one thing if
you do if you just remind yourself you
don't think this is a negative thing
that is not a negative thing it's the
only thing which is added value to your
life if you are here forever you would
be unbearable yes
yes is it very glad everybody dies
wondering if you just become conscious
of this one thing that always you're
conscious that I'm mortal you don't have
to think I will die today we don't
intend we want to live as far as
possible just you know one day I will
die if you just conscious of this one
thing you will naturally become
spiritual every day every moment if you
remind yourself this is a brief life and
motto one day I will end just to do this
for two days and see you will become
something truly fantastic within
yourselves if this is all and it's
simply beautiful that's all that's
needed if you want to know the value of
life just know that it's a brief
happening I think it's easy to lose
perspective of how great a life you have
just the fact that you are watching this
video you have access to the Internet
you are investing time in yourself in
learning and trying to get better puts
you ahead of most people in the world
and the problems that you have pale in
comparison to most of the other people
in the world and so just reminding
yourself of that that you are mortal you
will die and you have things way better
than most people can help lift you out
of a bad situation a negative situation
you feeling sorry for yourself you're
feeling down you're feeling upset that
you didn't get that goal or it's not
happening fast enough for you or you got
rejected or whatever reason you're upset
for I think it's really important to
pull from opposite spectrums at the same
time I think it's really important to be
insanely grateful for everything that
you have but also want more if you play
only on one side it's going to be hard
for you if you only are super grateful
for everything that you have in your
life and life is amazing and wonderful
and you're just so grateful to be in
existence then you're never pushing
yourself to get better right you're
never pushing yourself to do more and in
my opinion if you have the ability to
help others and to do more then you have
the responsibility to do it as well and
so if you have a lot of insane talents
and skills and you're not putting them
to use to help others because you're
just so grateful and life is so
wonderful right now something pushing
you to do more
and that's not great on the flip side if
you have no gratitude and you just
always want anymore and always pushing
always driving and always seeking to do
better and no goal is good enough and
just push push push push
you're not going to be happy either
right you're going to probably burn out
and crash at some point you're never
going to stop and think about everything
that you've done and accomplished and
and be a happy whole kind of human being
right and that's going to impact you
it's going to impact your families can
impact people you're trying to reach and
so I think both having insane gratitude
if you lost everything if I lost my
youtube channel right now I couldn't
post another video be really sad but
else you're really grateful for the
impact that I have had for all the
subscribers that I have touched or other
lives the people who have watched the
videos in standing people for that and I
want to do more I know I could do more I
know I can push harder I know I can do
better
I know we need to grind more I know I
need to create better content for you
guys so I think having both at the same
time and trying to pull from both
depending on on where you're at you know
if you're comfortable then you need more
this side you need more than I need to
do better I can do more and if you're
being too hard on yourself there may be
a little bit of perspective to say I've
really done a lot too I need to be
grateful for what I have that mix I find
really helps balance me out and
hopefully provide some ammunition and
guidance for you as well so the question
of date today is I'm curious how do you
balance gratitude conscious of your
mortality and pushing and striving and
wanting to do more I'd love to hear your
thoughts please share it down the
comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to Daniel Mauro Daniel
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word it really
really means a lot to me main and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever your one word is and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of n o
all right so give me go
first of all with the man in the cave
and this idea and the spot of the enemy
and that was a font that used to drive
me and can haunt me and make me get up
early and work hard to push myself
because I knew that somewhere out there
there was an enemy a real enemy a real
man a person a human that was waiting
for
and that was preparing for me and
therefore I needed to prepare for him I
needed to be ready I needed to be the
things I always talked about I needed to
be stronger and faster and smarter and
better so that when we did meet on the
battlefield I would be ready for that
rendezvous for that meeting that fate
that battle
and that thought that thought of the
enemy yes it absolutely fueled me it and
when I was a leader in the SEAL Teams in
charge of men it was even more profound
because I was thinking about that
rendezvous for everybody that I led
everyone I was in charge of everyone
that I trained and I felt that burden a
burden of responsibility to prepare
those men and protect those those man
knows those frogmen
those Warriors my brothers
[Music]
and it it was my burden to train those
guys and prepared them and and that
burden it may have made me a little bit
crazy a little bit paranoid a little bit
over the top but I didn't really know
any any other way
[Music]
and
so now I am no longer
a combat I no longer prepare men for war
so the drive and the motivation is from
a different place
[Music]
from a solemn place
the drive now and the motivation now is
not really for me
now it's from my friends not brothers
it's from
those seals that I knew
[Music]
and that I
cared about more than anything
and that they sacrificed everything
for us for me those guys they gave their
lives for us
and narrow
I cannot help but stink and remember
that every breath that we take is a
gift it's a sacred gift
from those men every day we have every
sunrise every thought and every smile
and every last
and I will treasure that attest that
gives the whole life
and I will not let it go to waste now
one second of it
you know cherish every moment of it and
I will live it
I will relive it in their memory
in spirit honor
[Music]